Mandy Moore opens up about a recent
betrayal a lot of
the actress and Mom of two shared this
selfie to her insta story Tuesday
looking upset revealing that she's at
work dealing with some upsetting
personal betrayal stuff from a new
person in her life and she's trying to
parse through what to learn from it
Mandy questions how to move forward
asking don't trust people don't be too
generous look inward at yourself and
like kind of forces you to hold up a
mirror to your own world and also gives
you permission to feel your feelings the
singer didn't elaborate on what happened
but she did say the unnamed person was
intimately involved in her life for a
short period man some people really let
you down the selfishness and lack of
respect and entitlement is wild in a
second post Mandy cracked a small smile
and says she's so grateful for her
family and life I won't let anyone Rob
that Joy from me onward and upward right
8. though this is a star later shared
this selfie throwing up a peace sign and
sharing some advice she got from a
friend let them know and Let It Go Mandy
didn't offer any more context into all
that but she seems to have shaken it off
enjoying some family time with her
five-month-old baby boy Ozzy
[Music]
Mandy shared that cute clip of her
little one on Instagram joking in the
caption baby pterodactyl contemplates
life so I'm excited to like be mom for a
minute and then figure out what I want
to do after that Mandy and her hubby
Taylor Goldsmith are also parents to a
two-year-old son Gus you're about to
welcome a second baby does Gus realize
that he's about to be a big brother
he doesn't we keep trying to tell him
baby breather and he he'll say baby
brother but I don't think he has no idea
what that means E.T was with Mandy last
year leading up to the birth of her
second kiddo shortly after she decided
to cancel the remaining dates of her
concert tour
[Music]
pour in our cups
and while Mandy said it was a hard
decision to step back from work she was
excited for the downtime I have to trust
my gut and give myself some Grace and
recognize that I can't do everything so
I was like you know what we'll we'll
definitely check back in and do this
again when um I don't have a baby in my
belly but I also was like you know what
it's okay to take a little bit of a
break I feel like this is the first time
in quite a few years that I've really
like power down a little bit and just
being a mom which is the hardest job of
all
[Music]